les foetus mathieu thierry et jean
michel
[Applaudissements]
elle va très bien on accueille
l'attitude chinois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
abo on accueille les m'abuse
isabelle valérie et julien courbet
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
savamment jumelles et où ces ménages non
il n'ya pas ma place je viens à toi vous
eu égard et siégeant fin avoir pas
besoin d'installer un vous inquiétez pas
on va d'abord accueillir donc ils sont
les deux ans jeff tuche
on va cueillir d'abord jean luc lemoine
[Applaudissements]
c'est magnifique j'adore mais cette
quête une folle cette tête est folle ça
va ah oui c'est très bien vous
m'expliquiez dans quel personnage
d'études vous n'êtes vous pas que ma
voiture parce que je suis obligé parce
que je pouvais y avait passé le costume
ou un autre jeff tuche cesu verdez
[Applaudissements]
il